foreign
let's go to Tom in Cleveland Ohio what's
up Tom
hey John how's it going good man go
Bengals what's up dude hey absolutely
absolutely wrong town but I'll go for
him the Browns aren't in anymore I was
gonna say at this point you all just
need to be cheering for any of Ohio and
group right
that's right yeah all right so what's up
dude so John I had a question
um I I wrote down a little bit of it but
main question is uh how to reunite with
my wife and marriage um and kind of a
big story behind that I did start my own
business in 2018 and I think that's kind
of what started it all
um she kind of took we're I'm married uh
to my beautiful wife since 2014.
um but she was doing the finances at the
time then of course when I you know got
into my own business uh I started
looking you know into the finances
numbers stuff like that and started
doing budgeting then I I noticed you
know I thought we were under
overspending and it turned into you know
trying to put the blame on her turned
into arguments over a two-year you know
period and it turns you know it turned
out to be I was being more like a dad to
her than her husband I was just about to
say that man yeah good for you good for
you for catching that and I yeah I
really I mean I I own up to it I know
what you know it happened in you know
long story short I wasn't her safe place
anymore now I mean I I did commit myself
about a year and a half ago you know no
more haggling over you know overspending
and stuff like that
um you know do it together which has
been good
although I I don't think we're back to
where we can just you know openly talk
cuddle you know simply enjoy each other
every day and date
and
how do I be that husband for her that
she adores you know
to be that safe space again
yeah number one do you just want to
applaud you man I wish every husband in
America would have the courage and the
strength to do what you've done which is
to look in the mirror and say I I
was doing the best I could with the
tools I had and those tools ended up
making a bigger mess than helping and I
want to I want to do something different
I want to be better good for you man
that's hard Tom that's hard so I want
you to own that okay
um
you're not gonna like my answer is that
cool
absolutely okay I'm I'm open and I'll
also say that a lot of the Beefcake like
yeah bro let's go snap into a slim jim
guys who listen to the show are gonna
naturally be like oh yeah whatever dude
and when I give you the answer okay and
I don't care because I'm right
and usually I'm like ah maybe I'm right
on this okay
you have gone away basically what you've
done is you have
um how to cease fire
you have not dealt with the issues of
peace
right
right and so
what's beneath the question what's
beneath your concern about overspending
so the magic you want to connect with
your wife reconnect with your wife
it's not on how many bullets are being
fired it's not you're spending too much
at Costco you're just blowing we can eat
for way cheaper than that why are you
spending so much it's not that
foreign
I'm I'm starting a new business
and I'm terrified that I'm gonna wreck
the family finances
I am
scared to death about money because I
grew up and I didn't have any money
growing up and I want to be a better
husband than my dad was for us and I
don't know how to do it I'm trying and
when I see numbers like this my body
just reacts in a terrified way
the magic word here is vulnerability
it's being honest with your wife not
about how smart you are and how good you
are at Excel spreadsheets and how in
nitpicking all the things she buys or
doesn't buy
beneath that is I can't breathe I'm
scared to death
we're staring down the barrel of a
recession I'm afraid we're going to lose
customers I'm trying to hang on to my
new business whatever is going on
people don't connect with one another
over strength
they can accomplish great things they
can become Partners but you deepen a
relationship through vulnerability
foreign
we had a good conversation and
completely openness and it it was like
um
you know
a couple hundred pounds off the
shoulders yeah and and um I was just I
I'm uh I'm in the middle of editing uh
my book manuscript here is a straight
and I don't know if I mentioned this on
the show the other day I was having a
conversation with somebody about it
this is strange to me that it I had
never thought this through but up until
like 100 or maybe 200 years ago
everybody lived in a house that was
relative like one room right maybe there
was a second room for the grown-ups but
everyone lived in one room
and so everybody knew if somebody had
diarrhea or if somebody was sick or if
somebody hooked up with so and so
the idea of Secrets is new
right the idea that I can go in my room
shut my door put a podcast in and go to
a completely different planet than my
kids and my spouse that I can pick up a
book and go down a rabbit hole or watch
my own series on my iPad in my room with
the door shut with my headphones on
our bodies aren't designed for that why
do I tell you that
what you just said the 200 pounds like
off your back
there is a biology to secrets so Secrets
will kill you
and secrets come out that angst you feel
that weight you feel about I feel like
when we're sleeping together you're not
fully with me and it makes me nervous it
makes me feel like I'm I'm alone it
makes me feel like right it comes out as
we don't ever have enough sex
or you don't ever do anything cool and
or you say nothing you see what I'm
saying and the secret is way down there
which is
man we're we're we're we're sleeping
together we are sharing a house we're
raising kids together but we are two
inches apart and 2 000 miles away from
each other all of that my brother I
don't care how tough you are how strong
you are how big your truck is well you
served in the military I don't care what
it it all starts with vulnerability
sitting in front of somebody and saying
this is what terrifies me about where we
are right now
and here's the ugly thing about
vulnerability she can roast you
right she can destroy you oh my little
pansy husband is just whining now oh
great you want me to here's your violin
and wives will do that it's awful
it's it's heartbreaking because the they
want to be adored they want to be loved
and the only way they can be truly loved
is if their husband has a space where
they can be safe and say I'm scared too
and that's just the world we've got
right now somebody's got to go first and
I'm pointing at you man go first so tell
me one thing what are you scared about
brother
well I I think you nailed it you know
just with the business although you know
financially it's not really uh
um a struggle but it does cross my mind
you know every day with uh you know gosh
what if this thing goes you know goes
belly up but
um you know it's been real good it's
been real good I got you know a good
support from her from the start and like
like I said I didn't notice that that I
was pushing it on her until you know two
years in and and uh you know I I really
regret it now but so let me let me tell
you something my wife told me um so
uh I I've worked in education for my
whole career
and without realizing it I'd worked in
non-profits my whole career I didn't I
didn't mean to never set out to I just
did
and in the the universities and the in
the schools that I worked at
um I got a salary
and I work 24 7 365 and my salary was
always the same
and then I got this job
and if I write another book
at night instead of sleeping instead of
hanging out with my kids I make more
money
if I take another speaking gig even
though I'm exhausted I gotta get on a
plane and fly to another city for two
hours and then get another I make a lot
more money
and so in the first three years of
working here I went crazy I've never
experienced this before and over uh it
was a few months ago now my wife
sat me down and said I get to speak into
this too because this is my house too
and this is our life we're building it's
not your job this is our life and she
said
the money bucket is full
and what she was telling me was
um and she also said the same thing
about my obsession with working out all
the time
she said
I am as attracted to you as I can be
like one more pound lost isn't going to
be like oh there it is and it's not like
I'm as attracted to you as I can be so
any more Obsession you have with getting
more ripped or more cut or more what she
said that's your problem that's not for
us
foreign you make plenty of money
any more money you need to go get is
because of your ego not because of your
wife and kids need it
and that was a huge conversation for me
and so I tell you that Tom to sit down
with her and give her a safe space
maybe start with I haven't given you a
safe space I haven't created a place
where you could even say your needs out
loud
what buckets are full
is it time for me to hire somebody so
that I can be home more and take some of
the burden off of you I can help with
bedtime with the kids I can take them
for walks so that you can shower by
yourself or use the bathroom by yourself
whatever stage you'll happen to be in
um and we're gonna make less money
because I'm going to hire somebody at
work and that's okay that's the season
we're in
or actually she's terrified about
finances too and so I'm actually gonna
work a side hustle I'm gonna I'm gonna
get another job and I'm gonna work crazy
for 14 months to get us in a position so
that right but let her for maybe for the
first time speak into
this world
because I want to change the
conversation in this country she's not
supporting your job
y'all are doing life together
and she may have a supporting role I
don't even like that language she's got
a equally and powerful and important
role it may not come with a paycheck but
it sure keeps the ship going right and
you can be the best fisherman in the
world but if there's not somebody
driving the ship or if the ship's got
holes in it you ain't catching fish or
you could catch a lot of fish you're
gonna sink to the bottom of the ocean
and so the supporting and like she's my
she's my number one fan and my support S
no dude it's a it's a team effort let
her speak into that but all of that
starts with you going first and you
being that word that we all hate man
there's just not a way around it
being vulnerable
saying I'm scared to death and I can't
breathe
I haven't been the guy that I wanted to
be
what kind of husband do you need in this
season and how can I help create a world
where you feel safe
how can I meet your needs so that you
have the capacity to help me meet my
needs
go first man
go first it's it's an honor to talk to
you Tom I wish more men had the courage
and bravery and strength that you do
hopefully they'll listen to this call
and be inspired thanks for being brave
man